♪ ♪
>> Sean: MORE IMPEACHMENT
HYSTERIA.
WE GOT HIM.
AGAIN.
EXCEPT, IT'S BLOWING UP IN THEIR
FACE.
IT'S TAKEN THREE YEARS TO GET TO
THE TRUTH.
IT'S PUTTING THE PRESSURE
SQUARELY ON NANCY PELOSI.
HERE WITH THE REACTION.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
HAS A PROSECUTOR NEVER LOST A
SINGLE CASE.
CONGRESSMAN, TELL ME.
WALK ME THROUGH THIS.
YOU ARE PROSECUTING THIS CASE
AGAINST JOE BIDEN.
HOW HARD WOULD IT BE?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I MEAN, THE BEST TOOL A
PROSECUTOR HAS IS THE ABILITY TO
CROSS-EXAMINE WITNESSES.
I EVERY WITNESS I CALLED WAS
CROSS-EXAMINED.
REPORTERS DO WHATEVER THEY DO.
I NEED TO EYEBALL THE WITNESS
AND JUDGE CREDIBILITY.
HERE'S WHAT MY FELLOW CITIZENS
BELIEVE.
IF YOU ARE GOING TO INVESTIGATE
ONE FACT PATTERN, YOU NEED TO
IDENTIFY A NEARLY IDENTICAL FACT
PATTERN.
WHAT THEY DON'T LIKE IS THE
DUPLICITY.
THEY HAVE THE TENDENCY TO
IGNORE.
YOU JUST PLAYED THE CLIP.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES SAID THAT HE WOULD
WIN
THE DUPLICITY IS WHAT DROVE ME
OUT OF POLITICS.
LOOK, NO OFFENSE TO YOUR
PREVIOUS GUESTS.
THERE REPORTERS.
I'M NOT.
I NEED TO CROSS-EXAMINE PEOPLE.
>> Sean: THE THING I NEED TO
UNDERSTAND IS WHEN YOU HAVE THE
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES SAYING, "YOU'VE
GOT SIX HOURS.
YOU EITHER FIRE THAT PROSECUTOR
OR I'M NOT GIVING YOU YOUR
BILLION DOLLARS."
THEY ARE OUR BILLION DOLLARS.
NOW WHY WOULD A VICE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICAN, WHY WOULD A
VICE PRESIDENT EVER WANT A
UKRAINE PROSECUTOR FIRED?
WHY?
BECAUSE JOHN SOLOMON TALK TO THE
PROSECUTOR.
HE SAID THAT HE KNEW THAT HE WAS
UNDER INVESTIGATION BY THE
PROSECUTOR.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" TIPPED HIM
OFF TO THAT.
>> Trey: BUT, I WOULD WANT TO
QUESTION JOE BIDEN.
BUT YOU WOULD ALSO WANT TO
CROSS-EXAMINE THE ONE FROM
UKRAINE.
THE CURSE OF BEING A LAWYER IS
YOU'D DOMINIC YOU REALLY DON'T
BELIEVE ANYBODY.
WHILE, BUT YOU KNOW WHAT, IT
WILL HAPPEN WHEN YOUR VIEWERS
AND OTHERS DEMAND THAT IT HAPPE
HAPPEN.
HE SPENT EIGHT YEARS COVERING
FOR BARACK OBAMA AND DID
EVERYTHING IN HIS POWER TO
PROTECT HILLARY CLINTON.
ALL OF THE SUN, NOW, IS A FAN OF
TRANSPARENCY.
I HOPE THEY CAN SEE THE
DUPLICITY OF A GUY LIKE ADAM.
>> Peter: AT LEAST HE THOUGHT
THEY WERE.